New York California and Washington have
some of America's largest homeless
populations they also have the three
worst coronavirus outbreaks suddenly
having a population that leaves needles
and garbage everywhere and defecates on
the sidewalk doesn't simply seem
disgusting though it is it seems
dangerous and insane
Jason trances Seattle area radio host he
joins us tonight Jason thanks so much
for coming on so look we can't we're not
epidemiologists we don't know if there's
a direct connection between the filth of
the places we just mentioned and the
outbreaks they're seeing now there's no
proof of that
but clearly this is a wake-up call for
cities that you can't have Calcutta like
conditions downtown no it should be I am
growing increasingly concerned the more
we hear about what we need to do to make
sure that the corona virus doesn't
spread seems to make sense to me because
I live in a home and I have access to
hand sanitizer soap and water
homeless people do not we had a case
today you and I last week talked about
the potential homelessness crisis and
where it intersects with coronavirus
well someone last night was put into a
motel in a city nearby Seattle it's
supposed to be an isolation site they
suspect that this individual who was
homeless has coronavirus they're waiting
for the test well this morning he left
the self quarantine site he went across
the street to a 7-eleven which he
allegedly robbed then he jumped onto a
bus and he left that is a problem well
we have people who are in desperate need
of support services because they're
living with potentially a mental illness
a addiction they're not necessarily
going to be put in a position where they
can just self quarantine they need the
help and we have yet to have a
significant enough plan presented to the
public that's addressing this particular
concern so in other words if you allow
your society to fall apart as they have
in Los Angeles in Portland in Seattle
when a crisis comes it might collapse
completely yeah I mean that's certainly
a concern I mean this is something that
was a long time coming and people have
been calling this out and saying you
cannot allow the homelessness crisis to
get this out of control you have
to actually have some semblance of a
plan and simply saying what we're not
going to sweep people from these
encampments and put them in the system
because we want to pursue politically
ideologically driven policy
prescriptions
remember we have a homelessness
situation that the City Council and this
mayor for tens is a direct result solely
almost solely on affordable housing they
blame Amazon Amazon is driving up there
is a lot sorry but that's not the reason
and waiting to address the actual
underlying causes so you can pass
affordable housing policies that's
problem totally and I and I say this is
someone who despises Amazon and I mean
that I tried to use Amazon as much a
dislike them but they're not the cause
of this you're exactly right there are
no the truth stop lying amen Jason great
to see you thank you thank you